ils étaient où ils sont là aussi les
rita mitsouko
si ces messieurs
vous connaissez tous le monde
edouard balladur
emmanuelle béart
roja n'a bacci saint catherine ringer
jean guy stephan
la
quatrième oui c'est vrai toi bien ça va
alors les rita mitsouko sept ans
d'absence
heureusement vous les rats parti il
avait manqué heureusement il y a
il y avait ça y est
c'est pas là
m
je
m'attends
et wade mitsouko non pas dans les sept
ans
tarifs 6 ans est quant à lui passé temps
une fois de plus je remets le cursus là
dessus ne vous souvenez vous pas il ya
quatre ans de ça qu'avec gynéco j'ai
chanté si j'étais riche des différents
consulté près au hockey tu es quelque
chose avait juste la nouvelle chanson
mais c'était quelque chose on était en
tournée à man vous connaissez tous ces
gens de chez eux alors
je dois je finis la aaa
voix
catherine ringer
alors les items il s'auto les rita
mitsouko reviennent c'est vrai que
depuis le 7 ans il ya eu pas mal de
tourner pas mal j'essaye de reprendre
mes esprits là alors voilà vous revenez
on va le faire parce que qu'on va le
faire parce que
vous connaissez des rita mitsouko edward
g rita mitsouko reviennent avec un album
qui s'appelle une frénésie que je viens
de vous montrer qui est superbe et on va
écouter juste un petit bout du premier
single qu'ils vont nous interpréter à la
fin de l'émission c'est du niveau de
leurs plus grands morceaux ça s'appelle
cool freiner
et voilà c'est cool frénésie
on écoutera la fin de l'émission et doit
vous ennuyer pas à vous restez avec nous
oui je vous écoute on est ravi que vous
soyez là moi aussi je suis ravi d'être
là bien alors je suis très inquiet
toujours avec les premiers ministres
alors votre disque la kul frénésie faut
dire quand même une chose c'est qu'il
est déjà avant d'être sorti en
précommande il est déjà directement
troisième des ventes
ne savais pas ça avant avant
avant d'être sorti en plus comment des
sorties il déjà troisième des ventes
absolument il ya un morceau en tous les
cas qui s'appelle c'était un homme qui
parle de votre on parlait tout à l'heure
avec roger hanin
du mal qu'il avait eue quand il était
petit du mal qu'il avait eue quand il
était petit alger parce qu'il souffrait
beaucoup de l'antisémitisme latent c'est
pendant la guerre c'est pas ringard
c'est quoi 42 43 c'est ça donc voilà et
vous catherine bas c'est un peu vous
parler dans cette chanson qui s'appelle
c'était un homme vous parlez de votre
père qui s'appelle samuel ringer qui est
juif en ligue 1 j'ai une gueule comme on
disait absolument et alors lui il a pas
eu de pot il était à côté d'eux vite
donc on lui a fait construire le camp et
une fois que le camp était construit on
a mis dedans
drôle de destin que maintenant les
allemands l'ont mis dans après il a fait
quoi il a fait neuf qu'en cinq ans ouais
c'est assez étonnant mais le nombre
comme ça et
spécial toujours lire genre de rapport à
ce genre d'histoire s'est jamais simple
vous m'avez dit une fois dans une
émission où on m'avait dit je sais pas
comment il a survécu a toujours été très
mystérieux là dessus
je crois comme beaucoup de jeunes têtes
que ça a été un [ __ ] mais oui je me
souviens cmn d'autres gens mais on en
reparlera longtemps comment tu as pu
dire ça comment tu as pu dire ça de ton
père mais franchement et je dois dire là
que lui qui était quelqu'un qui
dessinaient jir j'ai vu aussi des
anciens de quelqu'un qui lui avait sauvé
la vie par exemple si ça perd notre
titre qui s'appelle marqué l puisqu'on
est la règle on dire les choses
clairement qu'il y en a qui m'a raconté
que lui la première fois qu'il l'avait
vu il était dans un
baraquement et je suis pas comme il
avait du papier peut-être des choix des
camps de travail et ils dessinaient un
ss comme ça mais il était comme un ange
parce que il était au delà de le
détester au delà le bien du mal voilà il
était simplement dans le dessein de cet
allemand et c est ce genre de choses
aussi ma mère m'a bien expliqué qu'il
était haut dans un camping à juste après
la guerre quand ils s'étaient rencontrés
aux beaux-arts et qu' il y avait des
allemands dans ce camping et qu'il était
allé leur parler et qu elle l était
encore un peu dans les titres et
gaullistes évidemment elle à l'époque et
caetera et comment tu peux les piles y
avait une espèce de distance par rapport
à l'ennemi quoi neurologique et lui il
m'avait dit mais tu cèdes chez chaque
personne il ya un bourreau et en même
temps j'ai dans toutes les populations
il ya des gens bien et les gens moins
bien alors c'est vrai que c'est un sujet
vous avez déjà traité dans un album qui
s'appelle le marquer robert qui était un
de vos albums précédents les prix ni les
prix une chanson andré claveau les
années 50 je me retourne vers vous comme
je parle d' andré claveau parce qu'on
doit être trois ici à peu près savoir
qui c'est il avait détourné alors c'est
une chanson qui s'appelait le petit
train ça va dans la campagne et vous
l'aviez de détourner dans le train de l
or
justement le contraste cette chanson du
petit train dans la campagne et la
vision intérieure notamment et nous dire
ça m'avait fait après de brillants pour
dire qu'on serait une merveilleuse
chanson avec un rythme un peu la prinz
et les rita mitsouko qui apprennent
andré claveau je trouvais ça c'est assez
étonnant mais quand vous étiez convié
plus jeune à l'époque vous ai fait du
cinéma porno catherine quand vous
rentriez à la maison votre père il le
savait bien de toute façon que vous ils
vont aider à rentrer que les pistons à
la main quand même mais même j'avais
même
voilà j'en
viens prend
il disait rien parce qu'il avait vu pire
mystère et au mystérieux la chansonnette
ou saab est la seule ma villa va passer
à près de la tente a été commis boucher
toi alors
et tout le monde s'en fout là
non c'est extraordinaire c'est le
dictionnaire du rock and roll de michka
assayas way qui est magnifique édité
chez bouquins par guy schoeller et il ya
bien évidemment c'est ainsi une
encyclopédie du rock'n'roll et un grand
passage sur vous et sur la légende des
rita mitsouko pascal légende et dans
leurs canots il n'y a pas que de la
musique s'est pas bougé à prendre s à
fred chichin il ya de la légende la
légende de dudu des rita mitsouko c'est
le cinéma porno de catherine c'est vous
la route la dope la tôle ça fait partie
de la légende dans le rock'n'roll c'est
un peu le rock n roll stiller like comme
ça a pris un peu de dates c'est un peu
datés maintenant vous croyez moi je
crois
why à des trucs que je regrette
c'est pas chouette
oui parfois y'a des trucs au cas moi je
ne ferai pas bien vieux naturel on n'a
pas cet avis jacques demy en baisse à
lui
[Musique]
catherine interview jacques demy forêt
pendant chantant à quelle bonne idée est
ce que vous êtes alors prends le 7
péchés capitaux c'est plus simple est ce
que vous êtes avare
quand il faut dépenser pour un nouveau
rideau je regarde de ma poche et niveau
à point le fond les quelques sous sont
là et là il me reproche que le rideau
peut bien rester là encore dix ans
gentiment
est ce que vous êtes féerique oui ça
m'arrive oui et oui
envieuses
parfois
je regrette
ce que je n'ai pas
et ça m'arrête
au lieu d'aller la perse qui me tend les
bras je
m'accroche à ça
à cette gourmande
ce rêve bleu
ah la la
là
c'est merveilleux la gourmandise
quoi qu'on en dise y'a qu'ça kings
et au final vous êtes paresseux
besoin de rien envie de toi
[Applaudissements]
j'avais chanté ça
vous n'êtes pas et ça
c'est pour être sûrs de nous ira t il
une altitude abonnez vous il m'était
impossible eux